where is the B Midler full circle moment
too so that that happened back B Midler
yes that happened back in the 90s and um
I was singing a song called Love Is On
The Way and I was summoned to B Midler
and um she said you're an extraordinary
talent I think this song would be great
for a movie I'm
doing um and that's the rest is history
and you're and then the song is in the
first the song is in the first Liv club
that song when they break up and that
song that you all love but you don't
know who's singing it it's
me did you also get to perform it for
her recently or see her recently yes so
the full circle moment is I was called
to sing for bet Midler for her Kennedy
Center Honor that's right Kennedy Center
Honor I and I did a three song medley
With Love Is On The Way in the middle um
your new film our son is a very tender
subject um I'm very touched that there
is a film out there that navigates the
nuances of when you decide to go from a
family to co-parenting right this film
is you know people come into your life
for a reason a season and or a lifetime
and what I love about this film is that
the hope
space is the lifetime which is where
this couple gets to you know I'm a part
of the generation that fought for
marriage equality yes and with the right
to marry for queer people comes the
right to divorce we have to talk about
this and I star in the film with Luke
Evans who's so amazing I love him so
much amazing actor oh he's so good and
sings his booty off so I wrote uh a song
called always be my man and uh Luke and
I do it as a duet Robert Glasper
produced it and you know it's the first
time that um two gay out above the title
Hollywood actors have come together to
sing a love duet in a film it's a
tremendous movie congratulations on it
Billy Tru
Tru okay we do have a h a game here
called behind the seams yes will you
play behind the seams with us let's play
behind the the scen let's play behind
the scenes